[Music]
hello
no matter the science guy I am a guy I'm
a youtuber named Wesley and I I wanted
to ask you if since uh Carl Sagan was
your mentor if I'm not mistaken what is
your fondest memory with your mentor
Carl Sagan take care and have a good day
so my fondest memory with Carl Sagan oh
that's the the fondest might be
different from the most important the
fondest memories we were in class in the
spring of 1977 just a few months before
the Voyager spacecraft were launched in
August of that year and this is the
these are the spacecraft that have the
golden disc the record phonograph record
mounted on the side of them with the
presumption that an alien civilization
will find this decode the resonance of
the hydrogen atom binary symbology and
figure out how to play a phonograph
record from Earth at the right speed so
extraordinary idea but it was cool is
inspirational it brought out the best
and a lot of us and he would Carl Sagan
said what rock and roll song should we
put on and he said we are considering
roll over Beethoven but Johnny be good
and that everybody's no professor Sagan
know not roll over as a fine song but
the song you want is Johnny be good
Johnny be good by Chuck Berry and so
that is the song that's on the record
and that is a fond memory I I may have
led the charge but I was in my older
sister listened to that music
she was from that time doo-wop and the
beginnings of rock and roll so I was
very familiar with Chuck Berry and I
thought that's great and so he changed
Chuck Berry Johnny be good is the one
that's flying out into space on two
spacecraft then the most important
memory I had with Carl Sagan's no
questions ten years later I went to my
college reunion and they
18 87 and I arranged with Carl Sagan's
assistant to spend about five minutes
with it maybe I was ten minutes which
was a biggie he was a superstar by then
he had done cosmos he was being asked to
speak all the time he'd written these
great books poster bar award-winning
books and I asked him I can do it I want
to do this kids show about science what
should i do i've been doing
demonstrations about bridges and he says
no no don't don't do engineering to
science and then he said kids resonate
to pure science that was the verbiage
resonate and that really stuck with me
so if you ever watched the old Bill Nye
the Science Guy shows we did our best to
use to show you to me to show you pure
science rather than technology and the
show we did about computers which is
nominally a show about technology I did
my best to focus on the big ideas
switches and binary and commands that
take place without a human having to sit
there and tap the button so I I claimed
that that meeting the Carl Sagan and the
end of maybe the end of May 1987 changed
my life so the fondest memory was
generally be good the most important one
was resonate to science
[Music]